the volume of a cube is equal to its
length times its width times its height
a cube with side x has length x with x
and height x so its volume is equal to x
times x times x or x to the third
shane takes a big cube of butter with
side length five from the fridge so i'm
assuming well they're not giving us the
units maybe it's five centimeters with
five with side length five from the
fridge maybe i'll go with five
centimeters that seems reasonable then
he cuts out a little cube of side length
two from one of the corners of the cube
write an expression that describes the
volume of butter left
so let's think about it the original
volume of butter that was let's say it's
they're saying side length five i'm
visualizing it as five centimeters its
volume is going to be five times five
times five which we could just write as
five to the third power
and then he takes out another he takes
out a little chunk from that and the
chunk the volume that he takes out is
the volume of that little cube and that
little cube has side length two so its
volume is going to be two times two
times two or another way of writing that
is 2 to the third power so it's going to
be 5 to the third minus 2 to the third